The next set of lectures deals with cancer is an evolutionary process.
We're going to be looking both at the micro evolutionary,
a clonal evolution that characterizes every cancer,
and we're also going to see how follow genetic tools help us to understand the
history of cancers is the grow and metastasize.
Let's begin with some cancer basics types of cancers,
hallmarks of cancers,
prevalence of cancer trends and cancer risk,
and why we are susceptible.
Okay.
First and definitions.
A tumor is any abnormal swelling of the flesh,
and it's derived from land for swelling,
and it is not synonymous with cancer.
Yeah.
Cancer is a group of diseases that are characterized by uncontrolled growth and
spread of abnormal cells with the potential for invading and disbursing.
A neoplasm is an abnormal mass of cells that's caused by overproduction and to
benign.
Neoplasm is localized and not cancerous.
For example,
skin moles.
However,
they can also be pre-malignant.
A pre malignant neoplasm doesn't invade and destroy,
but given time they can evolve.
So a classic example is a colon polyp or a dysplasia that is an abnormal cell
development.
A malignant cancer is one that is,
has metastasized clonality means descent from a single progenitor cells,
so all the cells within a clone have a single genotype.
Cancer is traditionally have been classified a number of ways.
One is by tissue type,
so there are carcinomas which are from FSC glial cells.
They form 90% of all tumors.
They're derived from ectoderm endoderm.
There are sarcomas which are derived from connective tissue.
They are about 2% of all tumors and they're derived from Misa derm and then
there are leukemias which are circulatory or lymphatic.
They form about 8% of all tumors and they are derived from mesoderm.
Okay.
Then there is classification by cell type.
Yeah.
Cancers can come from squamous cells,
which are flat.
They can be myeloid that's coming from blood cells.
They can be lymphoid.
That means that they are derived from lymphocytes are macrophages and they can
be at nominees,
so that means they are derived from ductal or glandular cells.
That would be colon,
thyroid and prostate cancer.
Yeah,
so cancer is many different diseases and they have many different
characteristics.
What are its hallmarks?
Cancer cells no longer need external signals to stimulate their proliferation.
They become autonomous.
They ignore signals to shut down their proliferation.
They suppress their own program,
cell death,
so they will not undergo apoptosis.
Okay.
They can divide indefinitely.
They do this by stabilizing their telomeres.
They have increased mutation rates.
They become genetically very heterogeneous.
They can evade the immune system.
They can induce angiogenesis.
That is,
they can induce the growth of new blood vessels.
They can metastasize,
which means that they can move and colonize new parts of the body.
So those are the hallmarks of cancer.
Now what about the prevalence of cancer?
The lifetime risk being diagnosed with cancer in a country like the United
States is about one third.
The lifetime risk of breast cancer in women is about 12% about one in eight
autopsies on individuals who died of other causes reveal many covert malignant
cancers in premalignant carcinomas and prostate,
breast,
kidney,
thyroid,
and other sites.
Yeah,
we all have free cancerous mutant clones.
Thousands of them.
Yeah.
If they live long enough,
all men would probably get prostate cancer and all women would probably get
breast cancer.
To give you some idea of the burden of this disease.
Here are the estimated number of cancer deaths in 2006 in the United States for
men and for women.
I'll just mention a couple of the top ones.
In both cases,
lung and bronchial cancer was the most frequent kind of fatal cancer for men.
The second was colon and rectal cancer and for women it was breast cancer.
The third for men was prostate and the third for women was colon and rectal,
so there was a sexually,
a sexual or a system cancer that was in the top three for both men and women.
Breast cancer was a bit more frequent than prostate cancer.
Then the fourth most frequent was pancreatic cancer.
Yeah.
Now,
if we look at risk of death by cancer from 1930 to 2003 what we see is that in
some cases a few,
there was considerable improvement.
For example,
the risk of death from stomach cancer in men has been going down.
However,
the risk of death from colon and rectal cancer,
prostate cancer,
pancreatic cancer and leukemia has been pretty stable.
The risk of death from lung cancer rose and then started to fall.
And this,
uh,
tracks cigarette smoking.
The picture in women was a bit different.
The risk of death from uh,
colon rectal cancer has declined a bit in women.
The risk of death from stomach cancer as in men has declined quite a bit.
However,
for some of these other cancers such as ovarian cancer,
breast cancer and so forth,
that risk is pretty stable.
And women started,
uh,
getting killed by smoking related lung cancer a bit later than men.
And they have not yet benefited quite as much from stopping smoking.
Yeah,
no,
we have more cancer than do other species and there are at least four reasons
for that.
We now have a post reproductive lifespan.
We've domesticated ourselves and that's less important to natural selection.
So we have a period of our life in which we are surviving,
but natural selection is not improving our maintenance.
We have highly invasive placentas that are produced by stem cells that are pre
adapted to metastases.
We are mismatched to risk factors that are generated by civilization.
So to a certain degree,
cancer is a mismatch disease.
Those factors include tobacco,
alcohol,
a high calorie,
high fat diet,
Aaron Water Pollution,
and contraceptives.
Some of our reproductive cancers may be a proud product of our unique sexuality.
We have continual cycling,
continuous receptivity,
and the potential for continuous activity so that there's our mytosis.
There are cell division's going on and reproductive tissue all the time and
humans,
and here are just a few figures to make you remember that.
We're talking about aging,
things like smoking and things like contraception as being cancer risks in
humans.
So to summarize,
cancer is a disease that is caused by inappropriate and uncontrolled cell growth
and movement.
It is a collection of diseases,
not a single disease.
It is an increasingly important source of mortality in developed countries.
If we live long enough because we had escaped death for other reasons,
we would probably all die of cancer.
Our ability to treat cancer has not improved nearly as much as our ability to
treat other diseases.